prime minister of Cambodia as co-chair
the president of the European Commission
of course and the president of the
Philippines as coordinator of the EU
asean relations
we have just published or we're in the
midst of publishing the Declaration on
the website of the European Council so
please check that out
there is also interpretation into Khmer
for the media joining us and I would
first like to invite the president of
the European Council to take the thrill
I hope that the interpretation
thank you good afternoon everyone this
Summit today was historic bringing
together the leaders of the EU and Azan
for the first time a special sent to my
church prime minister consent chair of
asean and present marcosis Asian
coordinator for relations with the
European union today we are endorsing
our EU as end plan of action until 20 20
27. we also just concluded our EU asean
comprehensive Air transport agreement
the first ever region to region Aviation
agreement and we signed our partnership
and cooperation agreements with Thailand
and Malaysia these agreements will
strengthen our political dialogue and
boost our cooperation with the two
countries
today the EU asean celebrated 45 years
as partners and this month also marks
the two years anniversary of the EU and
asean becoming strategic Partners the
eus and partnership is unique it brings
Europe and Asia closer together to
increase the security and prosperity of
our citizens the EU is asean's second
large for investor and third largest
trading partner together we represent
over 1 billion people in 37 countries so
our partnership is a major force with
great potential to tackle Global
challenges like climate change digital
transition and free and fair trade the
indo-pacific its origin of growth and
opportunity and as a strategic Partners
we are strong advocates for
multilateralism and the international
rules-based order we share the soon
believes that double challenges can only
be addressed by working together and
today's meeting is also an opportunity
to boost our cooperation for greater
prosperity and one way to do that is
through trade trade is a powerful engine
for growth and for creating closer ties
between our regions our trade agreements
with Vietnam and Singapore are a good
example and you are working on trade
agreements with other countries in the
region we can also Forge Stone ties for
the root of our planet climate changes a
threat to everyone's existence and we
share the same objective we owe it to
the next Generation to cooperate on its
Global challenge together we also
discuss the importance of the digital
transition this will play a massive part
in the success of our societies so we
need to band together to develop safe
fair and inclusive digital economies we
also discussed the war against Ukraine
and its dramatic consequences of the
world especially on energy and food
security this war blatant evaluates
United Nations Charter and the attempt
to change internationally recognized
borders by force is not acceptable we
will never accept it we also discussed
the crisis in Myanmar that negatively
impacts stability in the region and we
continue support as an efforts to
address this crisis we support the full
implementation on of the Five Point
consensus and the personal investment of
prime minister hunsen
finally we discussed our intensified
security cooperation with several Asian
and asean partners including Maritime
security Maritime security is vital for
the world Israel is vital also for
Europe due to the importance of trade
rules and their protection it's in our
mutual interest to bolster our
cooperation in this area
this has been a memorable day as an
encount on the EU to be a steadfast
partner together we'll make this
partnership even stronger I thank you
thank you president may I invite the
prime minister of Cambodia to take the
floor please
Excellency Madame ladies and gentlemen
I want to start I raise my agreement to
what Excellency Michael has been raising
for me
I start my warmly welcome to all the
take part in the press conference today
marks a very special moment for our
partnership
with the successful and fruitful
organization of the asean EU
commemorative submit
I would like to share the optimism and
confidence as expressed by his child
Michelle and Her Excellency
regarding the positive advancements of
relation between our two regions and to
express that my belief that our
cooperation will be further deepened and
become more comprehensive with mutual
benefiting and we live with our open
frame and constructive Dialogue on a
wide range of topics that are relevant
and significant to our region
what makes our partnership even more
important is the development of
worrisome and franchise situation as the
world is facing the biggest trial and
seen before
instance geopolitical rivalry between
two Powers have shaken International
order and threatened stabilities peace
and prosperity
admit the escalation of unconflict and
War facing as two regions
on the war in Ukraine we reaffirm our
firm position
on the respect of for sovereignty
territorial Antiquities and political
independent
and we object the annexation
and the tread
or Jews of force against a sovereign
state
we underline the importance of immediate
cessation of hostilities and the
enablings of conducive environment for a
peaceful settlement of dispute in others
to pay the wave for Rapid Safe and
unhindered access to humanitarian
assistance for weak teams who are most
in need
foreign
I've been mentioned
uh what is our hope is that
the I2 region
has been connected eventually quickly
far away but we are connected become a
strategic partnership and what is the
main goal
that we can find in our meeting
is the free trade agreement between
asean and EU the two region
that work has needed to be done
as quick as possible thank you for
having your attention thank you prime
minister
Madam president can I invite you yes
thank you very much dear prime minister
Hansen dear president Marcos dear shall
ladies and gentlemen we had an excellent
Summit today with our asean partners
quite a special Summit too indeed
because it marks 45 years of relations
between us and it's a perfect occasion
just to open a new chapter in our
partnership
we are what you just said and called
strategic partners
we stand behind this term what stand
behind this term is the reality of two
regions that have so much in common
despite being a world apart
we are the two most successful Regional
integration projects in the world
we share the same unyielding commitment
to multilateralism and the international
rule of law
that means the same rules for all
whether big or small
and we both want to relegate the notion
of spheres of influence to the past
where it belongs
the European Union pleads for closer
cooperation between the EU and the asean
partners
Russia has Unleashed its war of
aggression against Ukraine war has
returned to the European continent and
it is clear that this is not solely a
European problem problem but the world
is feeling the brutal shock waves of
this war on food prices
on energy security and all this is a
stark reminder
that today in this world of
interdependencies there is no such thing
as a European problem or an Asian
problem either all the challenges we
face today are of global nature and
therefore affect all of us
you Asian know what is at stake and
therefore we are very grateful that you
have signed the Treaty of Amity and
cooperation with Ukraine
we very much welcome that the more acute
Global challenges are the stronger our
partnership must be
and today we indeed discuss several
strands of work to reinforce this
partnership the first one is energy
we want together to accelerate with our
partners the clean energy Revolution
so today we launched a Just Energy
transition partnership with Vietnam for
example similar to the one we have with
Indonesia
and we have also decided to start an EU
asean new energy dialogue because we all
know renewable energy is not only good
for our climate but it is also homegrown
and therefore creates Independence and
security of supply
second point is Trade A lot has been
said on trade we want to trade more with
each other
we already are each other's third
largest trading partners
our free trade agreements with Vietnam
and Singapore are delivering that's
impressive
so the European Union wants to conclude
more such agreement agreements with
adiane countries and our ultimate goal
would be to negotiate a region to region
free trade agreement
and my third and last point is on
infrastructure
because our energy and trade cooperation
will only reach its full potential
if it is underpinned by the right
infrastructure
today team mural put forward a 10
billion euros investment package under
global gateway
and let me end prime minister Hansen by
thanking you for your excellent
chairmanship this year
I'm now looking forward to working with
Indonesia under its chairmanship of
asean in 2023
we have behind us over four Decades of
partnership and we will continue
championing peace stability and
prosperity together thank you very much
thank you madam president
may I invite the president of the
Philippines to take the floor please uh
excellencies ladies and gentlemen good
afternoon we had an extraordinary
opportunity today to collectively look
back on our shared successes and to
exchange views about our prospects for
the future
we look back on asean EU achievements
most recently the signing of the asean
EU comprehensive Air transport agreement
that was signed last October and the
adoption of the plan of action to
implement the asean eu's Strategic
partnership for
2023 to 2027.
we noted the continued strengthening of
cooperation between our regions
throughout the pandemic through the
following mechanisms the asean regional
integration support from EU plus the EU
support to higher education in the asean
region they enhanced Regional dial ieu
asean dialogue instrument the EU asan
cooperation on sustainable use of
peatland and haste mitigation
biodiversity conservation and management
of protected areas in Asia
the integrated program in enhancing the
capacity of aha Center and as an
emergency response mechanism
and the asean EU migration and Border
Management program phase two to name but
a few
we appreciate the EU the EU member
states and the EU financial institution
on short team Europe for the combined
response of over 800 million euro to
fight the Health social and economic
impact of the coronavirus pandemic in
asean
as we move forward towards post-pandemic
recovery we eagerly anticipate the
resumption of negotiations for the
establishment of an asean EU Free Trade
Agreement and of the asean EU trade and
investment work program
I am pleased that today's Summit imbued
all of us as Ashan and EU leaders alike
with a sense of renewed commitment to
continue nurturing and expanding our
unique Asian EU partnership
which will serve us well as we are
squeezed by the Myriad challenges that
we have just discussed
such as the supply chain issues brought
about by the pandemic the global threat
to food and energy security made worse
by the conflict in Ukraine and to the
societal and economic Havoc wrought by
climate change to name a few
I am particularly pleased that this
Landmark Asian EU commemorative Summit
was shepherded to conclusion during the
Philippines coordinatorship for asean EU
dialogue relations and that the adopted
Asian EU joint leader statement is
reflective of the broad nature of our
relations and shows clear commitments
from both sides to further enhance our
relations
we hope to achieve more Milestones as
the Philippines continues to guide the
asean EU dialogue relations until 2024.
I assure my fellow asean member states
and All European Union member states
that the Philippines will continue to
expand
all efforts available to ensure that the
implementation of the plan of action to
implement the asean EU strategic
partnership for 2023 to 2027 proceeds as
intended we will strive to expand and
deepen our cooperation in the priority
areas of post-pandemic economic economic
recovery strengthening Public Health
institutions Maritime security and
cooperation
Environmental Protection and sustainable
economic development combating of course
climate change and connectivity with its
new definition which goes beyond the
strict definition of digital
connectivity but connectivity in all
manners by air by land by sea by digital
means
we also uh will work for the digital
transition and the lessening of the
so-called digital divide migration and
gender justice
we look forward to nurturing and
bringing forth asean EU relations to
Greater Heights in our role as country
coordinator for asean EU relations in
the next two years
before I end allow me to thank your
excellencies EU council president Xiao
Michelle
EU commission president Ursula of
Wonderland
Czech prime minister Peter fiala and all
EU members State leaders for your very
warm welcome that you have given us all
here in Brussels and we look forward to
the next commemoration of EU
relationships thank you
thank you Mr President we'll now take a
couple of questions let me start with
someone from the Philippines we had
Alexis Romero from Philippine Star yes
please
good day uh president Marcos how are you
doing
managing okay thank you very much
uh president Marcos you cited in your
speech earlier the need to go beyond
declaring respect and support for
unclose and to see an effective
application of the unclose to address
Maritime disputes and we all know that
this include the South China Sea Rao
what concrete measures can the asean and
the EU undertake to ensure the rule of
law in disputed areas beyond the usual
strongly worded statements well this is
so this is one of the reasons that we
had this uh we have these conferences is
to map out any possible actions that
might be jointly taken because of every
action that might be taken that objects
or
brings a uh brings light to a possible
violation of the unclose is much
stronger when it is brought about by a
group of Nations such as asean and if
the EU now with our strategic
partnership is able to also join their
voices to that then that will be much
stronger in the terms of actually being
able to Force what unclos is is all
about their commitment by the eu's
commitment which is which is found in a
joint declaration the eu's commitment to
uh the even the doctrine of uh of uh the
doc the doctrine of behaviors in the
South China Sea is already a very very
big uh very very big step for us in the
Philippines for example and for all the
countries around the South China Sea uh
that we now have the support a strategic
support from not only the member
countries of EU but of EU itself now
because it EU and asean together
comprise the largest most well organized
Regional aggravations then that will be
very very strong that will be a very
very strong position to be able to
negotiate even individually for the
Philippines or jointly with asean or
even with the EU us perhapses us
a third party to for us to take action
and to negotiate further uh these
difficulties that we are all having to
face uh with the problems in terms of
territoriality in the South China Sea
thank you we have a another question
Rosie a big shot yes from channel news
Asia please
thank you very much Rosie burchard
reporting for channel news Asia CNA to
president Marcos and prime minister
Hinson the EU has announced this 10
billion euros of infrastructure
Investments now that is just a drop in
the ocean really when you compare it to
what the Asian development bag estimates
is needed in terms of investment to keep
up levels of growth in asean what would
you have liked to see would you like to
see more can you give us some insights
into that and to the uh to presidents
Michelle and and Wonderland we heard a
lot about a potential block to block
Free Trade Agreement there now I believe
that's still pretty far off what would
what are the biggest barriers in your
eyes is it Myanmar is it about climate
policies from the asean side what do you
think needs to happen to be able to get
there thank you very much
go ahead
well I think the the the the the the the
one who can best answer that will be the
uh the donor of the 10 billion uh 10
billion Euro and we would like to ask
them how they would want us to uh to use
their hard-earned money when it comes to
uh to Asia so perhaps a president Bishop
no maybe maybe I will try to to answer
those questions first of all we are
absolutely determined to uh to uh
upgrade the level of ambition in terms
of a strategic partnership with the
assign countries is very clear and this
is also very important to take into
account the fact that the EU is
mobilizing money in order to make a very
tangible the bilateral Partnerships we
have with each of the asean uh the
members of this asean organization each
of the asean countries and this is an
important signal that we want to send uh
to to the to the leaders but also to the
people in that region point one maybe
with a smile another information that
you tend to share yesterday with some of
the Asian colleagues sometimes it would
happen we have some difficulties we've
seen the EU to be on the same page
sometimes we have divisions we have
difficult questions we have difficult
topics but one thing is absolutely
certain when we have on the agenda of
the European Council our relationship
with asean spontaneously immediately the
27 members says we are all on the same
page we are absolutely motivated to
strengthen the ties we have exactly the
same assessment within this
strategic importance for all of us to
develop and to make more tangible this
partnership with that region and this is
a transition to the certain part of your
question the trade agreements you know
this is a general debate across the EU
We Believe In The Free Trade we believe
in the globalization but we think at the
same time that we need to work for more
common standards more similar stand and
that's not to think more into account
our common goals in terms of climate
change for instance in terms of Labor
conditions for instance and it's very
good that we have demonstrated that it's
possible with some of the countries of
asean to have treated agreements and we
can observe that this is very positive
on both sides it's it's delivering
concrete and tangible results in terms
of increase of the volume of the
economic exchanges between those
countries and the EU and this was told
by the president of the commission it's
not a secret that we have also explored
tools exploratory tools with some other
asean countries in order to identify how
we can try to make some progress and
maybe to launch negotiations in the
following months or in the near future
and there is another dream we have we
have the dream to make possible sooner
or later
EU asean Free Trade Agreement but of
course you know to make it happen it's
also important that within the asean
steps are made in terms of economic
integration it's not exactly the same
situation in each of those countries and
it's probably also in an encouragement
with respect for the asean countries uh
to uh to to to observe some some
progress in terms of economic uh
integration you can see that you are
really motivated we are very proud
because this statement today is a very
strong message this is a strong impetus
for the for the future the concrete
projects uh on the table and we are we
are very optimistic and confident that
on a regular basis we'll have the
occasion to meet at the leaders level in
order to assess what we did and what we
need to do you know to make sure that we
are we are implementing what we have
decided if I might just uh add something
uh it is remarkable actually to see uh
during our meetings how uh despite the
marked difference differences between EU
member states and asean member states
that it is remarkable that we identify
as the same we identify the same
priorities as EU together as asean does
as the EU seems to also have the same
priorities and those are the in the
areas that we spoke about Environmental
Protection sustainable Economic
Development combating climate change
connectivity cyber security digital
transition migration gender justice so
it is as I said just as it is just an
indication and a manifestation of how
Global we have actually become and
although we come from very different
places from different very different
conditions uh we have a same a very
similar view a very similar world view
of the challenges that we all face
you want to say first yeah go ahead
I would like to add
please put on the earphone
would like to eat
the response from a child Mission and
Atlanta Marcus
our point is that asean
not just to wait
need to not always waiting for the help
from EU but we need to see the
complementary League
the economy of the two region
it's true that European country
are more advanced
but
Europe and as in
is not just a place to receive only a
system from Europe
in this situation that as in and Europe
agreed together
to have the Free Trade Agreement
together
we
should we don't want our people to
remain poor and then remain preferential
treatment from EU
we would like to run free trade
agreement between the two blocks
what do you mention whether there is any
obstacle uh with the proper Myanmar we
should not put politics
to hinder the Free Trade Agreement
at the openings which
the speech of President of Indonesia
mentioned generally the partnership
needs to be equal
cannot use the law from one side to
apply on the order
we need
that the two party need to be equal
to implement the quickest possible
not just to base on the situation of
Myanmar and any country and then allow
it to disturb our efforts
with the establishment of the future
agreement between the two blocks
in reality
for human rights
in relation to this and that is new I
would like also to act
whether EU signing agreement with how
many countries in as in and I know about
human rights over there
not everything are the same
but we have command point
Target the goal
to be connected between the two regions
the economy that is complementing to
each other
that the point that
reminds us in to try to stand up
to be partner
with equal to BCU thank you
Madam president yeah indeed you are
right global gateway is a much bigger
program 300 billion
for investment worldwide
and there are different regions with
different needs
the advantage with asean is
that we are meeting a highly developed
economy
and therefore the investment is not only
the crucial point
but as this is public investment for us
is important to have these
infrastructure projects and by
infrastructure I'm not only speaking
about old-fashioned infrastructure
terminology but in the sense that
President Marcos was describing and what
we need there is the incentive of the
public sector
as joint actions where it is needed
a conducive environment for example
regulatory environment
the private sector
and the exchange of Technology
and this is growing on three
Partnerships that we are developing
together the asean EU green transition
partnership
the asean connectivity partnership that
starts this year
and the asean EU energy dialogue and
this is the overall concept so you're
right the 10 billion are one part but
certainly not the whole picture of um
the way we address the projects
now what the region to region free trade
agreement is concerned we started to
negotiate in 2007 and a few years after
it stopped
and then for a while nothing happened
and then
um with the one or the other member
country of asean we were able to develop
a free trade agreement
therefore we have now building blocks I
would call it that name it's much more
mature
and this encourages and I'm very pleased
to listen to our guests this encourages
us to think in a broader Spectrum for a
region to region Free Trade Agreement as
we have already experienced now with
building blocks it may be that first of
all the one or the other free trade
agreement with individual countries of
the asean is coming first but we have no
experience
the free trade agreements that are in
place are delivering so they show the
success and we have proven that we're
able to match the different interests
thank you
um yes Finbar please
thank you very much Finbar Birmingham
with the Hong Kong newspaper of the
South China Morning Post a lot of talk
about the um the things that you have in
common but just reading the uh The Joint
statement
um there certainly are some differences
particularly on Ukraine where it says
most members strongly condemned the war
in Ukraine and stress that is causing
immense human suffering
um to the uh to prime minister Hansen
president Marcos could you explain why
it isn't all members that are condemning
the war in Ukraine uh just a follow-up
question
um asean is often portrayed as a swing
state between the big powers of the
United States China and Europe
um I'm wondering from uh your both of
your perspectives whether you uh welcome
the European Union to compete with the
United States and China or whether
indeed you you do see it in that way
thank you very much
me
some good
I should underlying a bit on this point
it's true that
in as in
our country do not have the same
position
the decision at the U.N
some country vote to support
some food abstention
for Cambodia
Vivo support
the U.S Security Council resolution
condemning The Invasion
the annexation
of land
and assassin chair
we also coordinate to issue the
statement
on the dialogue
or ceasefire
between Russia and Ukraine
we do not agree with the aggression
the Jews of force
or the annexation of land
this position
we are not only the one who support
but we co-sponsor that U.N security
Council resolution at the U.N
and
relationship to position
and this new grand issue
Cambodia also make decisions already
in order to send the minor trainer with
Japan working with Japan to have the
Ukraine demanded provide among them
training and we also accept 15 Ukraine
in January
to
come and then be trained a destroying
man and in a humanitarian season and we
send a person not to fight against
Russia in Ukraine
please I cannot see Michael tell the
police Philippine position thank you
perhaps I should um answer the second
part of your question uh in the about
the competition between the United
States and China
um and if it's that what we want believe
me we would rather not have these
tensions in our part of the world now
this is the last thing that we would
like and we the Philippines for for for
our part have taken an independent
policy and we absolutely refuse to go
back to the situation of the Cold War
where we have to pick sides in terms of
who the superpower is that we are
aligned with uh what we what we say is
that to be put it very simply is that in
the Philippines our foreign policy is
the policy for peace and for the
national interest so foreign policy will
always be guided by a commitment to
peace and the pursuit of the national
interest uh in terms
uh yeah and and then the in terms of uh
uh that competition as I said we have to
find I think all all of us member states
especially in asean have to find our own
our own way however I think it I think I
would not be uh overstepping by saying
that we agree in the sense that we are
committed to the idea that the future of
the Asia Pacific region should be
decided by asia-pacific countries and
not any other power outside of our area
thank you we have one more question I
believe uh yes from Nestor Corrales
please
also from the Philippine daily Inquirer
yes good afternoon Mr President Marcos
um what has been the eu's response to
your call to concretize the loss and
damage Concept in relation to climate
financing and what measures can be done
to ensure that major polluters will be
made accountable
it's a it's this very tricky question
um and I brought it up simply to
illustrate that EU has in fact been at
the Forefront uh in this kind in the
kind of um uh shall we say compensation
for climate change and however the issue
of damage and loss is still although it
is a big step forward that we all now
accept both developing and developed
countries now accept the concept of
damage and loss uh the actual number is
very very hard to determine and beyond
that even if we are able to quantify the
dimension loss you say it's 100 million
dollars whatever the number is what do
we do with that number who do we go to
who do we who who who pays the bulk of
it uh I I however I sense that there is
a there is a willingness for the
developed countries to participate and
to help in mitigation mission to help in
adaptation for those countries like the
Philippines most of the countries around
asean that are very vulnerable there is
a willingness to help but how to provide
that help is still a question that we
cannot definitively answer that is why a
lot of work has to be done and I have
brought it up with the EU and I've said
that this is an important issue
especially for the Philippines and for
many many other countries
but again it's uh the work that we have
ahead of us to be able to come to some
kind of agreement as to what damage and
loss actually means and what how will
the compensation for that damage and
loss be uh be be made and for for in my
part I think until we are able to
determine that I think we should think
of what we can do in the future and that
I think has a has great potential to be
to to be put into a effect
in the short term rather than in a very
long term
thank you thank you for um joining us
for this press conference
check out the joint declaration which we
have published thank you and see you
tomorrow
and I would first like to invite the
president of the European Council to
take the floor then becoming strategic
Partners the EU as and partnership is
unique it brings Europe changes a threat
to every